[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend zweimal hatte es probiert
zwei mal ist es nicht passiert erst
heute hat er wahr gemacht es braucht
keinen zweiten wahlgang friedrich merz
hat dem ersten schon fast zwei drittel
der abstimmenden cdu mitglieder für sich
gewonnen
nach allen umwegen nun ein klarer sieg
jetzt und erst jetzt kann die
selbstfindung der union als
oppositionspartei beginnen das berichtet
genetischer und dann ein gespräch mit
dem sieger von heute wer wird neuer cdu
vorsitzende nach befragung der
mitglieder 1 gelingt der cdu wieder
nicht etwas für sich zu behalten dass
friedrich merz die mitgliederbefragung
gewonnen hatte war schon vor dieser
präsentation durchgesickert
62,1 prozent die cdu basis überrascht
die gesamte partei wie klar wie
friedrich merz als scheffel das ergebnis
souverän rücken der kunden
was war ihr erster gedanke oder sind sie
in die luft gesprungen oder haben sie
die faust geballt oder was haben sie
gemacht
ich hab im stillen wow sagt aber nur
ganz still und es ist triumph
gesänge sind ihr fremd einer triumphiert
zwei andere verlieren und angela merkel
verliert mit die basis will den mann der
merkels politik als wortwörtlich
grottenschlecht kritisiert hatte
verlieren tut weh bei den beiden hier
zeigte sich
entschieden und jetzt wird die cdu
gemeinsam kämpfen für unsere
christdemokratische politik für unsere
werte und wie wir deutschland gestalten
wollen viel erfolg und der cdu in
deutschland der klare sieg vom märz
zieht fragen nach sich weil er auf
fraktionschef werden sieht er sich als
nächsten kanzlerkandidaten
märz leicht aus flüchtet sich erst mal
in die rolle des übervater parteichefs
ich weiß was da für uns alle auf uns
zukommt ich weiß was das für mich
persönlich bedeutet aber ich nehme diese
nominierung unserer mitglieder ich freue
mich darauf auf gute zusammenarbeit mit
wirklich allen
mit wirklich allen heißt auch mit ihm
und der csu
bin sicher friedrich merz wird ein
starker vorsitzender werden und ich
glaube dass wir nicht sehr gute
zusammenarbeit haben werden wie gut sie
miteinander können sehr gut was zu
beweisen ist denn markus söder und
friedrich merz haben ihre antipathie oft
genug begründet und anders als vorgänger
laschet wartet friedrich merz auf keinen
angriff aus bayern die nächste große
aufgabe für die csu wird sein die
landtagswahl im jahr 2023 zu bestehen
das wird nur dann gut gelingen wenn das
verhältnis zwischen cdu und csu
sehr gut sehr konstruktiv ist der cdu
chef in spe diktiert der csu eine
messlatte er selbst hat mit dem ergebnis
auch eine erhalten denn hinter sehr
guten ergebnissen stecken sehr hohe
erwartungen die basis hat entschieden
friedrich merz muss nun liefern und darf
zudem die enttäuschten in der cdu nicht
ignorieren
guten abend herr merz genannt der kleber
nun werden sie also endlich vorsitzender
wie soll das die cdu retten
nun ich stehe ja zunächst einmal zur
wahl nämlich auf dem bundesparteitag im
januar und da wählen wir nicht nur den
parteivorsitzenden sondern das gesamte
präsidium und auch den bundesvorstand
neu und das muss ein gutes team werden
und dann gehen wir zusammen an die
arbeit jetzt wurden sie ja zwei mal
sozusagen von mehrheiten abgelehnt sie
sind zweimal gescheitert und jetzt ein
fulminanter erfolg was hat sich denn in
den wenigen monaten dermaßen fundamental
verändert dass der sieg jetzt dann war
na ja wir haben das erste mal in der
geschichte der partei die mitglieder
beteiligt an dieser personalentscheidung
wir sind jetzt in der opposition
und ich bin wieder zurück im bundestag
also es haben sich im grunde genommen
alle wesentlichen einflussfaktoren für
eine solche wahl geändert und das
ergebnis ist klar und eindeutig und
darüber
freue ich mich nicht nur über mein
persönliches ergebnis ich freue mich vor
allem über die riesige beteiligung die
wir unter den cdu mitgliedern hatten
zwei drittel haben teilgenommen und
diese abstimmung das ist ein
sensationeller erfolg jeder der sie
kennt jeder der ihren lebenslauf kennt
beschreibt sie als ein mann der tat der
gewohnt ist das wenn er was sagt dann
dinge passieren ein mann der exekutive
ist denn die mühselige opposition arbeit
eigentlich ihr ding
naja ich habe ja dass etwas zweifelhafte
privileg aufgrund meines alters dass nun
alles schon mal erlebt zu haben ich war
ja 1998 1999 dabei als wir vor 25 jahren
in die oder 2 und 23 jahren in die
opposition gegangen sind ich weiß was
das bedeutet aber ich habe immer gesagt
parteivorsitzende der cdu zu sein ist
nicht nur regierungsämter zu haben
sondern ist natürlich auch die arbeit
für die partei und jetzt in der
opposition
wir sind nicht fünftes rad am wagen auch
wir haben einen wählerauftrag wir sind
konstitutiver bestandteil dieser
demokratischen ordnung und den auftrag
den wollen wir erfüllen und den will ich
erfüllen nun muss ihr ziel natürlich
sein dass diese ampel koalition nur eine
runde vier jahre im amt bleibt und die
cdu dann mindestens wieder an der
regierung beteiligt ist die erfahrung
zeigt so einfach ist es nicht als die
spd gemacht zweimal verloren hatte war
sie 13 und 7 jahre war sie zweimal 16
jahre im aus und die cdu hat zweimal
verloren war einmal 13 und einmal sieben
jahre aus
oppositionsarbeit ist langfrist arbeit
sagt die deutsche geschichte ja und so
werden wir sie auch an legen aber
jederzeit natürlich in der lage auch die
regierungsverantwortung wieder zu
übernehmen und wir haben mit dieser
bundestagswahl jetzt etwas erlebt was
wir bisher auch nicht kannten in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland nämlich wahlergebnisse die
zweier koalition nicht mehr erlauben
sondern ein wahlergebnis das das erste
mal ein dreierbündnis erfordert und was
das in der perspektive der
regierungsarbeit bedeutet werden wir
sehen meine vermutung ist der kleber es
wird in zukunft häufiger
regierungswechsel in deutschland geben
nicht mehr alle vier nicht mehr alle 6
16 jahre sicherlich auch nicht alle vier
aber wir werden irgendwo dazwischen uns
ein pendeln also schauen wir mal wenn
sie in der neuen sitzordnung des
bundestages jetzt nach rechts von ihnen
aus blicken dann sehen sie eine breite
sehr bunte koalition
und auf der linken seite von ihnen da
ist nur noch die afd in welche richtung
muss ihre politik jetzt zählen wo haben
sie die größten chancen wähler zu
gewinnen die wieder zur cdu zurück
kommen der kleber wir schauen nicht nach
links und nicht nach rechts schauen
gerade aus und wir wollen die mehrheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
überzeugen dass die cdu eine starke
volkspartei ist und dass wir als starke
volkspartei auch in der lage sind zur
mitte hin zu integrieren und das wird
die aufgabe sein die wir in den nächsten
jahren zu erfüllen haben ich bin sicher
dass das geht ich bin allerdings auch
sicher dass wir in den sachthemen klar
sein müssen und dass wir für sachthemen
auch wieder authentische personen
brauchen das hat die cdu immer stark
gemacht und das wird unter meiner
führung keine one man show werden
sondern wir werden viele integrieren in
unsere gemeinsame arbeit und aus denen
heraus müssen sich persönlichkeiten
entwickeln die profil haben und die
themen authentisch in dieser politischen
diskussion die wir haben besitzen
außenpolitik sicherheitspolitik
innenpolitik rechtspolitik das sind
alles wichtige themen sozialpolitik
seien besonders wichtiges thema und da
müssen wir glaubwürdige persönlichkeiten
haben und es wird eine meiner
wichtigsten aufgaben sein dafür zu
sorgen dass sie entstehen können
heranwachsen können soll man sich
wirklich vorstellen dass das alphatier
friedrich merz jetzt darauf aus ist als
primus inter pares in einem
gleichberechtigten team sich einzufügen
jedes team muss geführt werden aber
führung alleine ist noch kein team und
insofern wenn sie meinen berufsweg
kennen wenn sie meinen politischen weg
kennen ich bin immer jemand gewesen der
wert darauf gelegt hat dass viele andere
mitwirken die müssen loyal sein die
müssen auch am gemeinsamen ziel arbeiten
aber dann müssen sie auch freiräume
haben nach außen aufzutreten und dafür
werde ich schon sorgen nun wird ja im
demnächst ihre bühne der bundestag sein
sie sind in keinem regierungsamt da
müssen sie hin
wenn der kanzler scholz einer seiner
berühmten reden gehalten hat dann kommt
als nächstes der führer der opposition
das ist der fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu
das ist im moment ralph brinkhaus ich
weiß die frage seiner nachfolge steht
nicht an wie sie immer sagen aber was
würde dann aus ihrer sicht dagegen
sprechen dass sie das selber übernehmen
schließlich sind sie gerade gewählt
worden der kleber die antwort gilt und
bleibt diese frage steht nicht an es
spricht einiges dafür beide aufgaben in
eine hand zu legen das gilt übrigens
auch für das amt des bundeskanzlers oder
der bundeskanzlerin und den
parteivorsitz darüber sprechen wir wenn
es soweit ist und die bühne des
parteivorsitzenden ist nicht nur der
deutsche bundestag in dem ich jetzt
wieder angehören die bühne des
parteivorsitzenden ist auch die deutsche
öffentlichkeit und zum beispiel abends
beim zdf bei claus kleber rede und
antwort zu stehen über die politik der
union das ist keine so langfristige
perspektive aber eine sachfrage möchte
ich gerne noch stellen die frage zur
impfpflicht da im moment auch im
bundestag heftig umstrittene frage sie
scheinen noch gar keine eigene position
da zu haben doch ich habe eine eigene
position in der letzten woche gehabt als
wir auf vorschlag der bundesregierung
eine abstimmung im deutschen bundestag
hatten über die impfpflicht für
bestimmte personengruppen dem habe ich
zugestimmt jetzt um die generelle
helmpflicht die generelle impfpflicht
steht möglicherweise im frühjahr an wenn
sie ansteht möchte ich eine ganze reihe
von fragen geklärt wissen unter anderem
die wie denn eine solche impfpflicht in
deutschland durchgesetzt wird wir haben
bisher kein nationales register wir
wissen nicht wer geimpft ist und wer
nicht geimpft ist und die frage des
vollzuges eines solchen gesetzes ist aus
meiner sicht mindestens genauso wichtig
wie die diskussion über die pflicht als
solches und deswegen muss die
bundesregierung sicherlich noch ein paar
antworten geben ich möchte uns alle
davor bewahren dass wir so wie wir sie
jetzt erleben mit der impfpflicht erneut
eine enttäuschung erleben sie gemacht
haben aber sie nicht vollziehen können
eine sachfrage brachten wir noch unter
viele andere werden kommen danke für das
gespräch und einen guten abend ich
wünsche ihnen alles gute und schöne
festtage
und das gespräch hatten wir um halb acht
und diese zeit jetzt sollte wohl der
erfolg gefeiert werden ab morgen wird es
dann darum gehen die verlierer
einzubinden wie das fragt na sein guckte
mir im journal update gebraucht die
korona zahlen sinken weiter nur viel zu
langsam um zu beruhigen so sagen dass
die fachleute minister lauterbach warnt
vor einer massiven fünften welle
nächstes jahr und da kommt es schon
ungünstig dass nach dem obersten
verwaltungsgericht
niedersachsens gestern nun auch das von
baden württemberg eine zweig regel kippt
da geht es um den zugang zu
universitäten in niedersachsen ging es
um einzelhandelsgeschäfte und beide male
sind die hohen gerichte nicht davon
überzeugt dass die beschränkung auf
geimpfte und genesene wirklich
angemessen ist so schwankt nun die
rechtsgrundlage für längst beschlossene
maßnahmen moldau und fabian köhler
bericht
er legt selbst hand an und ihm zwei
kinder
karl lauterbach in kinder im zentrum am
zoo hannover es ist der erste auswärts
termin des neuen gesundheitsministers
eindringlich warnt er vor einer neuen
massiven fünfte novelle wir sind in
einer schwierigen situation
die omikron variante wird auch in
deutschland sich durchsetzen davon
müssen wir leider ausgehen die situation
wird leider noch immer unterschätzt wir
haben in england derzeit an der
verdopplung zeit dass die zahl der
omicron fälle im abstand von ein bis
zwei tagen sich verdoppelt das ist eine
entwicklung die wir in der gesamten
partie noch nie gesehen haben
warnungen die bei manchen verhallen
hilfe und nur für begleiten ihn auf dem
weg zum niedersächsischen
ministerpräsidenten
vorbildlich nennt lauterbach die korona
politik niedersachsens weil kann diese
rückendeckung gut gebrauchen nachdem das
oberverwaltungsgericht lüneburg die
zweijährige für den einzelhandel in
niedersachsen kippte ich betreibe keine
kritik der gerichte dafür bin ich weder
zuständig noch qualifiziert das
verbietet sich natürlich aber trotzdem
möchte ich darauf hinweisen dass es
weder epidemiologisch noch
gesundheitspolitisch sinn macht eine
solche regel jetzt zu kippen das
oberverwaltungsgericht lüneburg hatte
entschieden eine beschränkung im
einzelhandel auf geimpfte und genesene
sei keine notwendige infektionsschutz
maßnahme und verstoße gegen
gleichbehandlung und mir fällt auf dass
niedersachsen jetzt das einzige land in
deutschland ist wo zweig im einzelhandel
nicht gelten soll das muss man
konstatieren seine landesregierung werde
sich noch vor weihnachten intensiv mit
den folgen des urteils befassen das
oberverwaltungsgericht lüneburg
argumentiert sehr grundsätzlich es sei
nicht ausreichend belegt dass sich
menschen überhaupt in geschäften
infizieren vielmehr könne es ausreichend
sein ffp zwei masken zu tragen und diese
argumentation könnten auch andere
gerichte folgen entscheidungen in bayern
und nordrhein westfalen stehen zeitnah
an die rechtsprechung im moment nicht
einheitlich baden württemberg kippt am
abend zweig für unis schleswig-holstein
erklärte kürzlich zweig im einzelhandel
für rechtmäßig virologen warnen vor
einer uneinheitlichen linie die
befürchtung angesichts dieser wirklich
hoch ansteckende navigon variante ist
schon dass wir im januar die maßnahmen
noch mal deutlich verstärken müssen
nochmal deutlich verschärfen müssen
deswegen ist es im moment sicher auch
einfach ein ungutes signal maßnahme zu
lockern in hannovers innenstadt freuen
sich vor allem einzelhändler hoffen nun
noch auf volle verkaufsläden eine woche
vor dem fest ich bin freudiger deswegen
weil es für uns viel viel einfacher ist
nicht jeden kunden zu kontrollieren und
dass auch ein klares statement ist für
alle kunden die nun endlich so kommen zu
können eben nur mit der maske
niedersachsen befürchtet nun dass mehr
ungeimpfte zum einkaufen ins land kommen
könnten die botschaft sollte eigentlich
eine andere sein
nachrichten und wir bleiben beim thema
wegen hoher corona infektionszahlen hat
die bundesregierung frankreich und
dänemark ab sonntag als hochrisiko
gebiete eingestuft auch norwegen der
libanon und andorra wurden auf die liste
gesetzt wer von dort nach deutschland
einreist und nicht vollständig geimpft
oder genesen ist muss sich zehn tage
lang isolieren die quarantäne kann
frühestens nach fünf tagen mit einem
negativen test beendet werden oder auch
in diesem jahr soll es kein silvester
feuerwerk geben wegen der pandemie gilt
in ganz deutschland wieder ein
umfassendes verkaufsverbot für
feuerwerkskörper der bundesrat stimmte
einer entsprechenden verordnung zu mit
der unfälle vermieden und somit die
krankenhäuser entlastet werden sollen
außerdem hat der bundesrat die
verlängerung des milliardenschweren
corona hilfsfonds für größere
unternehmen gebilligt bis ende juni
stehen damit kreditgarantien zur
verfügung die zum beispiel schon der
reisekonzern tui genutzt hat
russlands präsident putin fordert seit
langem ein ende der nato osterweiterung
jetzt hat moskau konkrete vorschläge für
einen neuen sicherheitspakt vorgelegt
demnach soll sich die nato aus osteuropa
zurückziehen und dort auch keine militär
manöver abhalten außerdem fordert der
kreml die ukraine müsse auf die
mitgliedschaft in der nato verzichten
das wies nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg unmittelbar zurück zugleich
zeigte er sich offen für einen dialog
mit russland das aber auch bereit sein
müsse spannungen abzubauen
vor dem hintergrund des russischen
aufmarsches an der grenze zur ukraine
hat die eu moskau entschlossen vor einem
angriff auf die ukraine gewarnt die
staats und regierungschefs erklärten
gemeinsam jede weitere militärische
aggression werde massive konsequenzen
und hohe kosten zur folge haben darüber
hinaus rief die eu die autoritäre
regierung in belarus auf alle
politischen gefangenen sofort
freizulassen
wie den gerade zu 18 jahren haft
verurteilten ehemann der
oppositionsführerin kichern of skye sie
svetlana tischen of ska jahr wird
gemeinsam mit veronika zepp carlo und
der inhaftierten maria kohl es nie
koffer mit dem aachener karlspreis
2022 geehrt die drei leitfiguren der
opposition von belarus sein ein
einmaliges vorbild gegen diktatur und
unterdrückung in einem unrechtsstaat
erklärte der vorsitzende des
direktoriums
mutig und ermutigend sei ihr einsatz für
demokratie und menschenrechte
die frauen stünden für den geist der
freiheit die verleihung soll im nächsten
mai stattfinden
vielleicht hatte die polizei ja
tatsächlich keine chance den täter zu
stoppen an dem furchtbaren abend im
februar letzten jahres als ein wohl von
schizophrenie und hass gesteuerter man
in sechs minuten neun menschen ermordet
die seine nachbarn und mitbürger waren
die er für fremde hielt man hätte ihn
vorher stoppen müssen als sein hass und
seine wirren vorstellungen
offensichtlich wurden also sich trotzdem
waffen beschaffen konnte ein für die
angehörigen der opfer bis heute
unerträglicher gedanke und jetzt hat die
bundesanwaltschaft auch die ermittlungen
nach hintermännern und mit biss dann
eingestellt es gebe keine hinweise in
diese richtung heißt es für die familien
wird so immer mehr der
untersuchungsausschuss des hessischen
landtags zur letzten hoffnung auf
gewissheit susanna santina verfolgt
willi baron wäre heute 24 jahre alt dass
ihr sohn nie wieder bei ihnen sein wird
macht niculescu und julia von sehr
traurig und in die trauer mischen sich
bei ihnen immer mehr fragen denn willi
wurde von einem rassisten ermordet weil
er zivilcourage zeigte und die polizei
nicht erreichen konnte
wir wissen heute die notruf erwartet und
unter besitzen aber
bis heute
keine grenzen
wo sind die konsequenzen
dieser aufnahmen einer
überwachungskamera in der tat sagt
zeigen oben rechts willis auto der täter
tobias er rennt nach den ersten morden
an ihm vorbei willi fährt mit seinem
auto zurück und nimmt die verfolgung auf
bis zum zweiten tag dort dort wird er
von tobias er in seinem auto erschossen
auf der fahrt das zeigt sein handy hat
willi dreimal die polizei angerufen doch
die nahm seine anrufe nicht an
und wenn die polizei antwortet zum sein
telefon
100 prozent lebt
die staatsanwaltschaft hanau hat vor
kurzem beschlossen keine ermittlungen
wegen des notrufs einzuleiten um so
wichtiger familie parolen der
untersuchungsausschuss auch die
angehörigen der anderen opfer sind heute
nach wiesbaden gekommen als erster war
es gewiss geladen sie beklagte eine
unwürdige behandlung durch polizei und
behörden in der tatnacht und danach und
schilderte emotional wie der verlust
ihres sohnes hat das leben ihrer familie
zerstört habe im untersuchungsausschuss
wird es in der nächsten zeit auch darum
gehen warum war der notausgang im
zweiten tatort versperrt was wohl fürs
zeitmesser chemie und hansa coach zur
todesfalle wurde auch die ermittlungen
zum notausgang hatte die
staatsanwaltschaft hanau eingestellt ich
will wissen wie das sein kann dass der
notausgang abgeschlossen ist und alle
sagen auf anordnung der polizei und dass
die polizei ist wusste und wieso wird es
dann eingestellt wer hat hier was zu
verheimlichen
ein weiterer punkt der viele angehörige
und ihre unterstützer beschäftigt ist
die frage nach dem täter warum hatte der
bekennender rassist tobias er eine
waffenbesitzkarte
diese wurde 2009 10 auf eu erweitert der
täter hat auf sich im internet
aufmerksam gemacht er hatte eine seite
wo er auch seine rassistisches manifest
hochgeladen hat und er wurde nicht
geprüft und er wurde nicht aufgehalten
niculescu baron machte heute im
zeugenstand klar dass er nicht verstehe
dass die staatsanwaltschaft die
ermittlungen zum notruf abgelehnt habe
und das obwohl sie in ihrem
abschlussbericht dass
organisationsversagen der polizei hanau
selbst dokumentiert hat sagt sein anwalt
das ist im jahr 2016 ein szenario
durchgespielt worden ein mobiler täter
mehrere tatorte und ist das festgestellt
worden in einem solchen fall werden
informationen über den aufenthaltsort
des täters nicht rechtzeitig zur polizei
gegangen genau das ist dann tatsächlich
geschehen seit anfang des jahres hat die
polizei hanau nein weiter leitungssystem
für willi palm kommt es zu spät willi
hat im juni von ministerpräsident
bouffier posthum die hessische medaille
für zivilcourage bekommen und in hanau
seine eigene gedenkstätte
julia und niculescu baron wünschen sich
jetzt konsequenzen für diejenigen die
dafür verantwortlich sind dass milli den
notruf nicht erreichen konnte
ein verständlicher wunsch nachrichten
von wirtschaft und von gilt die
wirtschafts- und finanzwelt steht zu
diesem jahresende massiv unter dem
eindruck der pandemie und den sich
aktuell verschlechternden konjunktur
prognosen heute sank der ifo
geschäftsklimaindex zum sechsten mal in
folge und sina mainitz auch die
bundesbank korrigierte ihre erwartungen
nach unten ja so ist es denn durch die
vierte corona welle die angst vor der
omicron variante und die lieferengpässe
fällt eine schöne bescherung für die
deutsche wirtschaft dieses jahr aus und
das sonst für händler so lukrative
weihnachtsgeschäft wird dieses jahr
durch die 2g oder 3g regeln empfindlich
gestört ja da herrscht keine
feststimmung der ifo index ist gefallen
er ist vor allem mit den bereichen
gefallen in denen die krone welle sich
auswirkt das heißt in der gastronomie
bei den hotels insgesamt bei den
konsumnahen
dienstleistern und auch im einzelhandel
insgesamt fällt deutschlands wichtigstes
konjunkturbarometer nun schon zum
sechsten mal in folge auch die
bundesbank hat ihr erwartetes
wirtschaftswachstum heute nach unten
korrigiert noch im sommer ging sie für
das laufende jahr von 3,7 prozent
wachstum aus nun sind es noch
zweieinhalb für das kommende jahr werden
nun nicht mehr 5,2 sondern 4,2 prozent
wachstum erwartet bei der inflation hat
die bundesbank ihre prognose angehoben
angetrieben von hohen energiepreisen
erwartet sie kommendes jahr eine
preissteigerung von 3,6 prozent am
aktienmarkt verdüstert sich langsam die
stimmung der anleger
der dax beendete den handel im minus bei
15.000 532 punkten
konjunktursorgen lassen die gewinne am
parkett schrumpfen und die hoffnung auf
eine weihnachtsrallye ist zumindest
heute in weite ferne gerückt und das zum
vierten advent vielen dank china nach
frankfurt
in der pandemie aus dem ausland
zurückgeholt touristen müssen sich an
den kosten der staatlich organisierten
charter rückflüge beteiligen das hat das
verwaltungsgericht berlin entschieden
abgewiesen wurde beispielhaft die klage
einer sechsköpfigen familie die aus
mexiko geholt worden war und 600 euro
pro person zahlen sollte insgesamt waren
es rund
67.000 gestrandete reisende die im
frühjahr vergangenen jahres zurück
geholt werden mussten gesamtkosten 95
millionen euro
die klimaschutz bewegung fridays for
future feiert geburtstag vor drei jahren
im dezember 2018 folgten erstmals auch
in deutschland junge leute dem aufruf
zur schul streiks von greta thunberg der
damals 15 jährigen schwedischen
klimaschutz aktivistin in berlin
demonstrierten zu diesem jubiläum rund
350 vorwiegend junge menschen für mehr
klimaschutz
sie forderten von der neuen
bundesregierung mehr einsatz zur
einhaltung des 15 grad zieles
zerstörerische naturgewalten in folge
von extrem wetter erleben gerade wieder
die philippinen durch einen der
heftigsten taifune der letzten jahre
kamen mindestens 24 menschen ums leben
der tropensturm rey hat vor allem im
osten und süden des inselstaates schwere
verwüstungen angerichtet dächer und
bäume weg rissen an vielen orten gibt es
keinen strom überschwemmungen und
erdrutsche erschweren die
rettungsarbeiten
300.000 menschen mussten sich in
sicherheit bringen
europa hat sich schuldig gemacht des
raubes der missachtung der gewalt und
der arroganz als europas kolonialmächte
ihrer raubzüge durch afrika machten
ungehemmt weil sie die menschen dort die
schöpfer solcher kunst als minderwertig
betrachteten primitive die keine rechte
bekamen weil die weißen herren dort kein
recht kannten das schicksal des
historischen königreichs berlin im
heutigen nigeria ist ein drastisches
beispiel für diese art von unrecht und
jetzt endlich kommt gerechtigkeit in
dieses thema sven ricken berichtet wie
das mark das hamburger museum am
rothenbaum die beutekunst nach 100
jahren im speicher noch einmal
prachtvoll zur schau stellt um sich dann
von ihr zu trennen sie zurückzugeben
dorthin wo sie hingehören eine positive
geschichte wenigstens jetzt am ende
der rapper man erzählt von einer zeit in
der noch ein kühl
1897 plünderten britische
kolonialtruppen nahezu alle kunstschätze
das kulturelle erbe des landes wenn der
protest rap macht das jungen leuten klar
auch in einer hamburger tauscht die
hansestadt zeigt 179 objekte aus dem
raub in dieser form zum letzten mal
kommendes jahr gibt die stadt die
kunstschätze an nigeria zurück in dessen
gebiet beliebt heute liegt
es ist höchste zeit dieses unrecht
wiedergutzumachen
diesen großen fehler der kolonialzeit
warum sollten wir das heute noch
tolerieren
hollerith zwischen 3 und 5 tausend benin
werke gibt es weltweit so die schätzung
rund 1200 in deutschland hamburg
startete vor sieben jahren eine
initiative um staaten museen und sammler
davon zu überzeugen dieses kapitel der
kolonialzeit endgültig zu schließen die
zeit war anscheinend erst jetzt reif
dafür es gab früher ja so eine situation
die ganz merkwürdig gewesen ist dass man
immer wieder hörte wenn wir das
zurückgeben kümmern sich denn dann die
afrikanische staaten überhaupt
ausreichend darum das ist völlig gaga
wenn es jemandem gehört dann gehört es
jemandem und wenn man es dann
unrechtmäßig entwendet hat dann gibt man
es zurück nach der plünderung durch die
britischen truppen landen die kunstwerke
in den kommenden jahrzehnten bei
sammlern museen und in dunklen kanälen
die seele eines landes geraubt je mehr
institutionen sich jetzt der rückgabe
idee anschließend desto mehr werke
tauchen auf ich glaube jetzt diese
eigentums übertragen hier in hamburg
stattfindet ist eine der wichtigen
momente aber auch die tatsache dass sich
deutschland bereits im april bereit
erklärt zu restitutionen war schon sehr
signifikant und hat auch innerhalb
europas vierte wirkt schon jetzt
bereitet nigeria seine jugend auf die
neuen perspektiven vor animierte
geschichte via internet gibt es bereits
echte kultur in neun museen die
zukunftsperspektive
bislang waren nur sehen für unsere
jugend nicht attraktiv es fehlen ja die
exponate etwas über unsere kulturelle
vergangenheit erzählen sie so kann
niemand etwas lernen das ändert sich
jetzt ergänzt
durch zuletzt auch die vielen reaktionen
in den sozialen netzwerken reckermann
der mitleid ausgelöst hat haben das
raubkunst thema in die digitale welt
geholt hamburg möchte mit seiner
rückgabe eine neue brücke bauen eine
kulturelle brücke auf den afrikanischen
kontinent
gute geschichte und sie warten auf die
heute show kommt gleich heute mit dem
satirischen rückblick auf chf gegen 0.20
ist hier nummer zeit für unser
heute-journal update bis morgen abend
und business wochenende
[Musik]
genannt das ist eine sehr eingefahrene
wetterlage die wir derzeit beobachten
mit diesem hoch über dem westlichen
mitteleuropa zusammen mit dem tief über
russland schaufeln die beiden sehr kalte
luft in richtung südost europa und die
erreicht sogar die ägäis aber diese
kalte luft ist gar nicht so weit
entfernt und wenn jetzt dieses hoch
zafira tatsächlichen langsam aber sicher
weiter richtung nordwesten zieht dann
könnte die kalte luft von osten
tatsächlich anfang der kommenden woche
mal den weg zu uns finden das müssen wir
noch ein bisschen abwarten und derweil
schauen wir auf das nachts wetter das
nach wie vor sehr bedeckt ist hin und
wieder bildet sich auch nebel und am
alpenrand ist es klar über den schnee
flächen dort wird es sehr kalt da sinken
die temperaturen bis minus 8 grad sonst
sind es in süddeutschland zwischen plus
vier und minus zwei grad im norden ist
es bei 8 bis 3 grad etwas milder
temperaturen morgen kommen und sehr
bekannt vor sie sind ganz ähnlich wie
heute sie liegen zwischen 6 und 10 grad
und im süden ist es etwas kühler mit ein
bis fünf grad auch am wetter ändert sich
nicht wirklich was es bleibt meist
bedeckt hin und wieder gibt es etwas
nieseln oder sprühregen und die sonne
sehen wir ganz selten im äußersten
norden schleswig holsteins westlich des
rheins vor allen dingen aber auf den
mittelgebirgs gipfeln oder am alpenrand
derzeit liegt ja schnee und das gar
nicht zu knapp zb in der birgter südlich
von oberstdorf bis zu 45 cm daran wird
sich auch in den nächsten tagen wenig
ändern obwohl es von tag zu tag kälter
und sonniger wird guten abend